hello my name is Igor brush stroke my
name is Richard so my name is nationally
my name is really a psychic they're
tough and determined to reach the top
Igor and his fellow students want to
take on the world the chess world
and their parents are happy to pay for
it by sending them here to the Russian
cheskel in Moscow
[Music]
this just makes you smart becomes you I
like to think calculate and make my
moves chess is logical truck market do
you have suddenly is it chess is
universal a seventy-year-old academics
and play a six-year-old child young
opinion and either could win by beating
a ship that brings people together all
over the world but not always in 1972
American Bobby Fischer faced off against
Boris Spassky of the Soviet Union was
dubbed the match of the century a
political power game in the midst of the
Cold War
[Music]
that was then today seven international
grandmasters train the 80 students at
the Moscow chess school
they might be young in years but many
have already won tournaments in Moscow
and around the country chess is back as
a national sport and so was the prestige
something even the youngest player knows
[Music]
chess tournaments like this where one of
the Soviet Union's favorite tools to
demonstrate socialism superiority of a
corrupt Western countries socialism may
have disappeared but is a decadent West
is still around at least in the minds of
many Russians the current world
championship in New York pits Russia's
own Sergey Karjakin against Norwegian
Marcus Carlson but is it a clash of East
versus West at the yeast gift restore
but the test was one of the best
traditions of the former Soviet Union so
it's good to see that tradition maker
resurgence by at the more can just not
sure but whether it's as political as it
was back then I don't think so you see
what them purchase is a return to
traditional values are yeast of a
thermogenic that you found on tennyson
after being buffeted by doping scandals
and corruption allegations the classic
board game of chess just might restore
some of the shine to Russian sports